welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of moon
night episode 4 which like mark and
steven made me scream holy hippopotamus
turns out i wasn't that delusional for
thinking some of this could be all in
steven's mind or could i still be
delusional probably still a bit
delusional i mean who knows what's going
on so i'm gonna break down this episode
shot by shot for the interesting details
you might have missed to best explain
one of the wildest twists we've ever
seen in the mcu and remember to support
new rockstars by checking out our moon
night inspired tomb of the moon gods
shirt limited supply running out fast
get it over at newrockstarsmerch.com and
when you get the shirt you're going to
unlock the added option to write in a
custom shout out that will appear in the
bottom of our midnight after shows and
thanks to kiwiko for sponsoring today's
video more about them later so we begin
this episode upside down as the avatar
for osiris places konshu zushapti in a
cubbyhole among several others our view
only finally orients riding itself on
this close-up of konshu making him our
compass our true north for what is real
this whole episode because without him
this hour mark steve and all of us are
lost i like how osiris avatar takes this
uncertain beat after placing the ushapti
since they have clearly stonified a ton
of deities not a healthy sign like a
warden wondering huh everyone is now in
prison are the laws too strict no it's
everyone else who's wrong also osiris
may be wondering if he could be the next
one among these figurines are a whole
bunch of them one with curved horns
another shorter one to the far left a
lot of these look like the larger
statues among the chamber last episode
towering over them i wonder if the five
members of the inead may have ushabti to
their ranking elders like ottoman shu
that could explain why four of the nine
indiana members are missing i also think
that towerette may be among these
figurines and i'll explain what that
means for the final scene especially
because in the closing credits of every
episode on the back right a tararet
ushabti appears alongside these others
which fill in the cubby holes we see in
the opening shot that tells us that
towerette must be banished which is a
very important key to how we interpret
the final scene throughout this opening
scene we hear several voices chanting
[Music]
as if these trapped gods and statues are
all haunting osiris demanding to be
freed then out in the desert a scarab
crawls up a mound and flies off now the
scarab was of course the compass that
was used to find amit sushapti and now
even this scarab compass is like uh
peace out you mortals suck now by the
way the hieroglyphics on that scarab
were translated to the phrase okepri
amid his boat primeval one whose
corporeality is infinity may you rescue
osiris a minitep true of voice khepri
being the sun deity represented by the
scarab which egyptians associated with
the way it rolled its dung across the
sand with the way capri rolled the sun
across the sky now remember last episode
steven joined koncho in casting that
illusion to make the heavens look like
they did 2000 years prior and when that
happened a little detail i liked
steven's mr knight mask wilted away
matching concho's dissipation just a
cool way of showing how steven was
losing a part of himself as well no
longer having the armor and healing
properties that really would have come
in handy when arthur shot him twice in
the chest but a detail that i loved here
whereas past episodes the crescent moon
always shined to reflect consuming at
its most powerful now notice how the
moon is in its waxing gibbous phase the
exact opposite of the waning crescent in
the lunar cycle which is a cool way of
showing khanshu's inverted totally
weakened state now actually by the way
in the credits of every episode of the
season on the written by title card it
reflects the way the phases of the moon
shift episode after episode from waxing
crescent to the first quarter to now in
this episode gibbous layla pulls a
jurassic park dr alan grant and lights a
flare to direct hero's men away from the
passed out steven and then insanely
throws another lit flare into their box
of shells to set them all off like
fireworks even though in the shot from
behind her she is clearly totally
exposed to all of those projectiles as
is steven folks the indiana jones antics
go way over the top of this episode and
i truly think it is by design to suggest
mark could be pulling all this from his
tomb buster movie actually as they drive
into the desert the next morning these
locations were the same parts of jordan
where they shot indiana jones the last
crusade so that familiarity is totally
intentional meanwhile may kellem always
look in this show and the way she plays
layla definitely evokes rachel vice from
the mummy movies i really think these
cinematic parallels are all by design
leila and steven agree to keep mark out
of it we are not it's just you and me
and the open road
we're gonna go on foot from here the
camera lingers on these three bullet
holes in the windshield which you could
see is representative of the three
altars we think make up mark's mind the
way that the holes can be in there
without breaking or shattering the whole
thing because mark is not broken those
three altars we assume are mark steven
and jake lockley as of this episode we
have not yet met jake they pass a goat
who stares them down in addition to the
christian associations between goats and
evil there was that moment with stephen
and hero in episode two
yes
where there is a goat there is a hero
now when stephen initially wants to make
a move on layla mark punches his own
face in the jaw
oh sh
another fight club reference tyler
durden does essentially the same thing
then after going back and forth with
layla stephen finally makes his move and
it is awkward i'm gonna go down okay
first
before i belay thank you yes steve you
totally misinterpreted it down to mean
uh not belay but you know another
another kind of down a sex kind steven
geeks out at the statues down there
they're just like
been standing guard for centuries i'm
right
i can't even
if if they just sprang to life right now
and
asked me a riddle for passage i'd be
thrilled i'll [ __ ] myself but i'd be
thrilled yes he's referring to the
riddle of the sphinx the sphinx being
the creature with the haunches of a lion
the wings of a bird it's best known from
greek mythology where it has the head of
a woman but in egyptian mythology it has
the head of a man to the greeks it
guards the city of thieves where it
poses the riddle to oedipus which
creature has one voice yet becomes
four-footed and then two-footed and then
three-footed an oedipus answered
correctly man who crawls on all fours as
a baby walks on two feet as an adult and
uses a walking stick in old age three
beings in one also parallels mark and
his alters each of whom have a different
stride yet speak in one voice and one
cannot help but draw a connection to the
caned figure of arthur harrow who ends
this episode using his walking stick
this is also of course a big clue for
the reveal of alexander the great for
the way egyptian iconography and obelisk
since sphinx has made their way into
greece was because of alexander's
occupation of egypt and his obsession
with egypt in the sand leila traces the
arabic letters going from right to left
because that's how arabic works ein and
elif her father's initials as we saw her
full name on her passport last episode
leila abdallah el fauli abdullah meaning
servant of god which is a bit ironic
because mark is trying to keep her from
being a servant to the god konshu while
exploring the tunnels leila says it's a
maze
it's amazing
no like there are six paths yeah
six of course since this episode ends by
suggesting much of this could have been
all in mark's mind it's worth noting
that the concept of a maze has often
been considered a symbol of the
subconscious mind back to greek
mythology the labyrinth and then
manifesting in contemporary media like
stanley kubrick's shining westworld and
the amazing series severance watch that
show it's so good this maze represents
mark's mind perhaps the six paths
representing as many as six altars
stored inside but steven traces out the
structure to show how this is modeled on
the eye of horus and its six parts
citing the symbol that some historians
interpret to represent the six senses of
thought sight hearing smell and taste
according to mythology horus's right eye
was the sun and the left eye the moon
and this is his left eye here so the
moon is always present in this show but
in the mythology there was a fight
between horus and his brother set and
set tore out the eye and the eye is
later healed and restored either by tot
or by hawthor whom we met last episode
which is why this symbol now represents
healing and protection i just like that
when stephen clears the sand to trace
this his flashlight now reflects off of
the metallic surface beneath to form the
eye of horus on the ceiling above them
as if either horus or hathor could be
watching over their deets here or this
represents the moon that konchu is
watching all of this then they come
across this mummification chamber used
by these undead priests who are buried
alongside the pharaoh on the upper level
mark finds some stuff that he says was
used in regeneration rituals which all
just leads to this gore fest in the
middle of the episode where the priest
extracts organs from harrow's man and
tries to do it to mark and layla who
knows why he's doing this layla comes
across as gaping pit reminding us of the
chasm that indiana jones has to make the
leap of faith across in the last crusade
as she has to make a bit of a leap of
faith in the scene her faith and her
love for mark despite the bad stuff he
was involved with she has to fend off
this priest monster by ripping off his
arm and shoving a flare in his face she
loves her flares 40 pieces of flare on
this one now this zombie priest makes a
clicking sound
which comes off pretty creepy but this
is actually the result of his tongue
being removed from the embalming process
also assuming his eyes were removed in
that process as well the clicking allows
him to echolocate his targets around the
tomb the way bats use similar clicking
sounds and when his hand reaches out of
the wall at layla it's very similar to
the frame of the corpse hand reaching
into the subway door in the comics when
mark's mental hospital reality warps
around him meanwhile stephen finds some
macedonian language on the foot of the
tomb actually if you translate the back
half of those letters they really
translate to alexander confirming this
huge discovery for stephen i think we're
looking
at the long
lost tomb of alexander the great whoa so
alexander the great you should know this
guy he was the one who by the age of 30
led the greeks to rule over one of the
largest empires in human history from
europe to india alexander was a lover of
egyptian history who also bore the title
of pharaoh he founded the city of
alexandria where many believe after his
death in babylon in 323 bc he could now
be buried somewhere in the city of
alexandria but his tomb has never been
pinpointed and verified so unless this
is all a fantasy and that might actually
be the case the implication here is that
alexander the great in the history of
the mcu was the final avatar of ahmet
and that alexander's military feats
might have been enabled by amit's power
and maybe even the cult-like love that
alexander inspired could have been the
same kind of cult following that arthur
harrow now enjoys famously the saying
goes that alexander wept because there
were no worlds left to conquer therefore
alexander might have been that past
avatar who betrayed ahmet he could have
been the one who sold her out to the
gods and her detachment from him is what
led to his death in babylon after which
point the indiana said ahmet you have
helped out humanity way too much no one
should have conquered that much turf you
a statue and then had someone stuff that
statue in his mouth wanted her to be her
voice eater eater i like how on
alexander's chest is a scarab necklace
with its wings open evoking harrow's
scarab compass that he uses to find her
ex marking the spot for amit sushapti
which is buried deep in alexander's
gullet alexander's axe that he's holding
might have actually been the one he
famously used to cut the gordian knot
but harrow reveals to layla that mark
was among the mercenaries who killed her
father and she confronts him talking to
you i'm talking to you mark
come on let's go let's go let's go yeah
steven immediately nopes out of this
awkward marital drama and i just like
how the frame breaks the rule of 180 to
show this transition awkwardly cutting
so that oscar isaac now switches to the
right side of the frame and mark affirms
that while he did not kill leyla's dad
he was still there my partner got greedy
at me he executed everyone at a dick
site he shot me too i was supposed to
die that night i'm assuming this partner
was frenchy to comp whose name appeared
on mark's flip bone promo footage has
shown the moment mark first got
possessed by konchu i assume next
episode of episode 6 will show us what
this backstory was harrow and his men
arrive dressed as sirens yes another
shakespeare reference after macbeth's
something wicked in episode 1 and the
romeo and juliet verona light of episode
2 the rest is silence are the final
words spoken by hamlet and hamlet after
his long drawn-out death from being cut
with a poisoned sword and his duel with
laertes after that cut hamlet actually
goes on and on for nearly 100 lines so
shakespeare ends his life with those
words and almost a self-satirical tone
like the kid finally shutting up after
going back and forth on death for five
acts when you think about it the line is
actually a pretty good pun the rest is
silence but also the rest is silence and
in this we can draw a comparison with
mark whom much speculation has wondered
might already be dead in this whole
series is his passage through the field
of reads and did it suck for you getting
rejected from the field of reads what if
that makes sense because i'm not dead am
i stevie
and harrow is now preparing to lay the
final nail in the coffin harrow does
this by shooting mark twice in the chest
and mark slowly falls backward matching
the fall last episode when he blacked
out similarly mark is out of control not
sure what form he's gonna wake up in
because he passes out from overhead in
just inches of water but when we cut to
him from below we are now several meters
deeper than him in that water as he
descends into this sunken place where
now you'll notice the bullet holes are
gone from his chest showing how mark has
sunken from his passage of the field of
reeds now more like that sunken boat and
poor sarcophagus in the tank as we saw
mark reflected submerged in that tank in
episode two now clearly moon knight is
redefining the future of the marvel hero
and our friends at kiwico are redefining
the future of play kiwiko sent me this
box kit for everything i need to make my
own pinball machine
it's meant for like kids and maybe kids
and our parents to make together this is
what it looks like in the picture in
this project that like five-year-olds
can do themselves i made this pinball
machine moon night theme summon the suit
and i'm very proud of myself for doing
it check it out boom
um
zero points now if you aren't very
familiar kiwico delivers just really
cool monthly steam projects they're
designed to help kids see themselves as
makers and creative innovators all while
being really fun at the same time each
of these crates comes with really simple
kid-friendly instructions plus all the
supplies you'll need to put it together
so that you won't have to make an extra
trip to the store they also come with a
custom booklet that teaches you about
the science behind the project and where
you might see it in real life and kiwi
go has something for everyone because
they have nine different subscription
lines for all different ages that cover
the full steam spectrum from science and
engineering to art and design it's a
perfect way to spend quality time with
your kids while sneaking in some
learning along the way so it really does
make a great gift for any of the kiddos
in your life or if you consider yourself
a child at heart and at times a child at
mind a great gift for yourself so if you
want to support new rock stars and work
your brain in all the right ways click
the link in the description below to get
30 off your first month of any kiwi co
subscription let's try to summon that
suit again
oh it hit the spinny part isn't that all
we're trying to do just hit the spending
part and now we find ourselves in this
low budget jungle set of tomb buster a
title clearly an indiana jones rip-off
even its name and nodded the tomb raider
franchise but this scene is totally
similar to the opening of raiders of the
lost ark when indy and doc ock found the
remains of the previous adventurer even
the music sting is almost note for note
john williams indiana jones theme
maybe so
you've got pluck
so the implication of this is that mark
might have pulled the name in the heroic
expertise of steven grant from this
movie almost like someone in our world
manifesting an altar named dr jones a
princeton archaeologist and adventurer
but notice how instead of the egyptian
moon god they explore the aztec moon
deity of koyashaki who is depicted here
with multiple faces like the split bust
of mark that we have been seen in the
closing credits imagery it's just
interesting that while ethan hawke's
analyst character later compares himself
to the villain of this movie this dr
steven grant really does physically
resemble arthur harrow his hair his
glasses his usage of the compass
actually that villain in the movie is
never named for all we know this indiana
jones figure might end up being revealed
to be the villain of that movie the kid
who looks up to him the hero just like
as we watch mark spector and steven
grant and arthur herrera on this show we
don't really know who the villains and
the heroes are because konchu is kind of
a dick this whole twist is awesome
several characters in the cast reappear
all of them now in this facility street
performer crawley is now calling bingo
numbers pulling them from his hat which
he holds out the same way as hat was
always laid out in front of him in the
park the bald man fidgets with a rubik's
cube almost completing the white side as
we saw in steven's flat i'm pretty sure
that's the tour guide dylan stevens date
sitting at the table behind the bald guy
the orderlies are bobby aka kennedy the
fake detective while the other pushing
us from mark's point of view here in the
wheelchair is billy aka fitzgerald their
names were a major clue of this reveal
because in the comics billy and bobby
are the names of orderlies who work in
mark's mental hospital also in the
comics crawley is revealed to be another
resident at the hospital at some point
the same way he is here the red yellow
and blue bowls of jello are just like
the brightly colored powder in all the
bowls that steven saw in the
mummification room donna is another
patient clutching one of the plush
scarabs that they sell in the museum
gift shop throughout this we hear the
ticking of a clock which we passed right
after we see donna but it looks like it
reads 11 25 but the hour hand ends in
the shape of a crescent moon but despite
the ticking sound the second hand of
that clock is not moving there's a
cupcake cart just like the cupcake van
that steven hijacked in episode one she
sketches a hummingbird with conscious
skull evoking both konshu of course but
also the hummingbird we saw in the
commune's nature footage on the dry
erase board are pinned some postcards
like the one stephen thinks he receives
from his mum here it is layla who does
it so maybe the mum he thought he was
connecting with was actually layla
there's a goldfish like gus on a stack
of books just like gus's tank and
steven's flat that is cluttered with
books layla appears chewing on a turkish
delight just like the ones that the
forger shared with her in episode three
lot of sweet snacks in this facility
notice how she has a little bandage on
her pinky finger with a red drawing of a
scarab on it this is a major clue
pointing to the possibility that layla
abdullah alfajoli could be an adaptation
of abdul
aka the scarlet scarab an egyptian
warrior who led the sons of the scarab
who fought against the invaders cap
human torch namor bucky spitfire and
union jack as other titles have done
retconning flag smasher as carly
morgenthau and laura barton as
mockingbird layla could be reframed as a
successor of a lineage of egyptian
protectors a man behind them gardens
like the gardeners at harrow's commune
layla says he won at bingo holding up
his card that shows the following
numbers dabbed b83 i23 n86 g65
g35 o67 and o55 and throughout this we
heard crawley call out the numbers b22
g15
oh t16040 something oh 73 and n39 folks
if you've ever played bingo these
numbers make no sense the b numbers go 1
through 15 i is 16 through 30. n is 31
through 45 g is 46 through 60 and oh is
61 through 75. most of these letters and
numbers would not exist in bingo also
crowley clearly said t16 as in tango 16
and there is no t in bingo in high
school spanish class i played a spanish
version of bingo called tango where you
say yo dingo i have it
bingo then a medicated mark falls out of
his wheelchair but the harness on his
ankle causes him to fall on the exact
same side of his face that he fell in
episode one when he landed in the alps
in episode two when he left out of bed i
love how those two moments set up this
reveal here in his hand is this hooded
and caped moon knight action figure
which if moon knight ain't a really
known hero in the mcu at this point
would there be an action figure of him
also another weird thing what was he
dabbing his bingo guard with i didn't
see a dabber in his hand then onto
harrow's office mark sees his painting
of the exact landscape of the alps where
stephen found himself in episode one but
harrow now the analyst of this facility
says we don't live in a material world
we live in a
psychic world i mean harrow's office
even has a bizarre design big columns
tall ceilings brick surfaces and arches
there's these headed vases just like the
ones that the priests store the organs
inside of in the tomb one has a falcon
head of raw as well as the hippo head of
towerette and this human head that i
think matches the sarcophagus of
alexander the great harrow has a cane
that mark assumes that he must have
mapped the ahmed staff over and of
course sandals just like the ones he
fills with glass and notice how mark
sees those sandals through the
reflection of a mirror a housefly lands
on mark's hand maybe a reflection of his
rotting corpse status back in the tomb
also reminding us of the final shot of
alfred hitchcock's psycho when norman
bates's mother voice said that she
wouldn't even have to let her fly that
landed on her also on the desk are a
bunch of sharp things that should not be
on a desk with this kind of facility
there's a large curved piece that
matches the shape of crescent moon as
well as a pyramid and if you look
closely at that vhs cover of tomb buster
it says when deeper in here steven grant
has no fear which isn't the case in the
final shot of the episode but maybe a
clue that steven grant in a place like
this is gonna be the more heroic figure
dr hero says i can't help you
if you don't help yourself which is what
harrow said after shooting steven in
that tomb but i can't save anyone who
won't save themselves by the door is
another statue the crocodile head of
ahmet and as harrow steps up to mark at
the door he's just framed with this
close-up of his hand on the cane the way
he's been framed in several other shots
like the opening scene of the series as
mark flees the hallways just warp the
carts are rolling on their own the
hanging lights just swing back and forth
looking a lot like the swinging scales
of amit's justice we've also been seeing
this hallway in the closing credits
imagery flickering from the storage unit
hallway into this one and if you
remember back in episode 2 the way
steven ran down that hallway is the same
way mark runs down this one both of
these forming a maze in his mind in one
room he finds this sarcophagus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the first time that the two
altars have actually touched physically
suggesting that they are in the same
sunken place inside of his mind they
actually had oscar isaac's brother
michael hernandez stand in for him
during these scenes the smooth camera
work makes it look like we never cut
from oscar isaac at the door to oscar
isaac coming out of the sarcophagus but
you can see there is a hidden cut on the
whip pan i also like here how mark is
dressed in lightguard where stephen is
dressed in darker clothes which not only
helps us distinguish the two but also
frames which one of these two alters is
closer to konshu mark notices another
mysterious sarcophagus that shakes in
another room that they don't open i am
assuming that this is going to be the
mystery third altar maybe jake lockley
whoever it was who stabbed those men on
the roof last episode and then we end on
this awesome moment
[Music]
[Applause]
hi
so this is towerette the egyptian deity
of childbirth and fertility who takes on
the appearance of a hippopotamus but
with otherwise human features the kind
of features disney plus definitely had
to cover with a more modest wardrobe i
just love the hippopotamus animation
details that they added like the way her
ears wiggle when she says hi and the way
her nostrils flare she's voiced by
actress antonia saleeb confirmed at the
red carpet premiere last month and she's
credited for this episode as well as
episodes five and six so we're gonna be
spending a lot of time with her so what
is going on well the moon knight comics
especially the jeff lemire and greg
smallwood run that seems most
influential on this series constantly
shift back and forth from mark's
supernatural experiences to a clinical
setting repeatedly making the reader
second guess what could be real and what
could be a delusion this state of
uncertainty is exactly what moon knight
is supposed to feel like and there is
enough surreality and falseness in both
mark and steven's experiences in the
outside world and their experiences in
the hospital to doubt the legitimacy of
either reality even before tower it
walks in no mental hospital looks like
this where's cupcake cards meanwhile all
the indiana jones stuff this episode was
also super silly and fictitious so is
anything on the show real well i see
three explanations first explanation the
past episodes with stephen and mark in
the outside world was all a fantasy
constructed by a patient in a mental
hospital a patient who still suffers
from delusions while in this hospital
kind of like how all of saint elsewhere
was in the mind of autistic child tommy
westfall patient who dreamt all this up
might be neither mark nor stephen who if
you think about it are both pretty
heightened realities but rather a more
grounded figure the guy and the other
sarcophagus may be jake explanation too
everything we have seen happen
pre-hospital is real but now after he
got shot mark slipped into a kind of
limbo state deep in his subconscious
that takes the form of a mental hospital
filled with people and images from his
life like dorothy gail after she hit her
head and went to oz or like tony soprano
when he had that hallucination after he
got shot but explanation 3 mark spector
has already been in the process of dying
a long drawn-out process like our boy
hamlet and this whole time he has been
passing through the field of reeds the
brooms were the reeds folks all four of
these episodes a purgatorial judgment
process for a man with d.i.d to reach
peace with his altars before the rest is
silence i mean i don't know but this
third explanation might help us
understand what this hospital now is why
it is filled with sarcophagi and tauret
now yes the hindquarters of ahmed are
that of a hippopotamus maybe they're
gonna draw parallel with amit being
three in one the way mark is and here
amit's alters are depicted as separate
people but again tauret is her own deity
the goddess of fertility i don't see how
fertility applies much to what stephen
and mark are going through but there was
a connection in the past if you remember
episode one when steven handled some of
those plush towerettes while doing
inventory in the museum bring those
hippos up here will you yeah sure power
weddit
the hippo goddess
which is why i think there could be more
to the opening images of this episode
the wall filled with the shopties dozens
and dozens of gods trapped somewhere
there was that one interesting line from
dr harrow where he quoted the villain of
tombuster no tree can ascend to the
light of heaven if it doesn't descend to
the depths of hell heaven and hell above
and below konchu accused the members of
the iniad for hiding in the overvoid now
i think we could be in the mcu's
underworld a realm that may end up going
by many names in the mcu maybe even has
already been introduced in the form of
the ancestral plane this is a
subjectively psychic dimension where
reality manifests itself in the eyes of
the beholder to a did patient a mental
hospital with egyptian flair because
trapped in him with this realm of mark
and his altars and projections of people
in his life are the other egyptian gods
that the iniad banished to the
underworld ahmet konchu and this sexy
ass toweret no tree can ascend to the
heavens without descending to the depths
of hell is also a paraphrase of a quote
from famous philosopher and
psychoanalyst carl young who said quote
no tree it is said can grow to heaven
unless its roots are in hell this was
young's way of saying human
enlightenment is impossible unless we
recognize our inner demons that
collectively haunt us this being a
reflection of this stage in mark's
hero's journey to descend into hell
before he can reach true consciousness
and again since a stone ushapti of
towerant appears in the credits of every
episode and presumably also in that wall
of cubbyholes with all the other stone
who shotties who have been exiled
somewhere that right there may be proof
that we are now in the duat the
underworld that all exiled gods are
trapped in and mark's soul is currently
with them back in episode two when
stephen was handed a pamphlet to seek
help from a mental health facility this
may all now be how his subconscious the
subconscious of a d.i.d patient
decorates the egyptian underworld of the
duat this show's version of the mcu
afterlife the ancestral plane valhalla
wherever the hell thanos went to in this
case how this hero takes the plunge into
the depths of hell and prepares to fight
his way back out of it and a reminder to
check out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com like this doom and
the moon god shirt it's just so
comfortable it's got a secret message on
it you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at e8 boss follow the new
rockstar subscribe to rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching konshu
[Music]
you